The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK so we're going to
do this thing of the hydrogen
atom and the algebraic solution.
And I think it's
not that long stuff
so we can take it
easy as we go along.
I want to remind you of a couple
of facts that will play a role.
One result that is very general
about the addition of angular
momentum that you
should of course know
is that if you
have a j1 times j2.
What does this mean?
You have some states of--
first angular momentum J1
that so you have a
whole multiplet with J1
equals little j1.
Which means the states in that
multiplet have J1 squared,
giving you h squared.
Little j1 times
little j1 plus 1.
That's having a j1 multiplet.
You have a j2 multiplet.
And these are two independent
commuting angular momenta
acting on different
degrees of freedom
of the same particle
or different particles.
And what you've
learned is that this
can be written as a
sum of representations.
As a direct sum of
angular momenta,
which goes from j1 plus
j2 plus j1 plus j2 minus 1
all the way up to
the representation
with j1 minus j2.
And these are all
representations or multiplets
that live in the
tense or product,
but they are multiplets
of J equals j1 plus j2.
These states here
can be reorganized
into these
multiplets, and that's
our main result for the
addition of angular momentum.
Mathematically, this
formula summarizes it all.
These states, when
you write them
as a basis here-- you
take a basis state here
times a basis state here-- these
are called the coupled bases.
And then you reorganize,
you form linear combinations
that you have been
playing with, and then
they get reorganized
into these states.
So these are called
the coupled bases
in which we're
talking about states
of the sum of angular momentum.
So that's one fact
we've learned about.
Now as far as
hydrogen is concerned,
we're going to try today
to understand the spectrum.
And for that let me remind
you what the spectrum was.
The way we organized it was
with an L versus energy levels.
And we would put an L equals
0 state here-- well maybe--
there's color, so
why not using color.
Let's see if it works.
Yeah, it's OK.
L equals 0.
And this was called n equals 1.
There's an n equals 2 that
has an L equals 0 state
and an L equals 1 state.
There's an n equals 3
state, set of states
that come within L equals 0 and
L equals 1 and an L equals 2.
And it just goes on and on.
With the energy levels En
equals minus e squared over 2a0.
That combination is familiar
for energy, Bohr radius, charge
of electron, with
a 1 over n squared.
And the fact is that for
any level, for each n,
L goes from 0, 1,
2, up to n minus 1.
And for each n there's a
total of n squared states.
And you see it here, you have
n equals 2, n equals 1, one
state.
n equals 2, you have
L equals 0, one state.
L equals 1 is 3 states.
So it's 4.
Here we'll have 4 plus 5.
So 9.
And maybe you can do
it, it's a famous thing,
there's n squared
states at every level.
So this pattern that
of course continues
and-- it's a little
difficult to do
a nice diagram of the
hydrogen atom in scale
because it's all pushed
towards the zero energy
with 1 over n squared,
but that's how it goes.
For n equals 4, you have
1, 2, 3, 4 for example.
And this is what we
want to understand.
So in order to do that, let's
return to this Hamiltonian,
which is p squared over
2m minus e squared over r.
And to the Runge-Lenz vector
that we talked about in lecture
and you've been playing with.
So this Runge-Lenz
vector, r, is defined
to be 1 over 2me squared p
cross L minus L cross p minus r
over r.
And it has no units.
It's a vector that
you've learned
has interpretation of
a constant vector that
points in this direction, r.
And it just stays fixed
wherever the particle is going.
Classically this is
a constant vector
that points in the direction of
the major axis of the ellipse.
With respect to this vector,
this vector is Hermitian.
And you may recall that when
we did the classical vector,
you had just p cross
L and no 2 here.
There are now two terms here.
And they are necessary because
we want to have a Hermitian
operator, and this
is the simplest
way to construct the
Hermitian operator, r.
And the way is that you
add to this this term,
that if L and p commuted as
they do in classical mechanics,
that the term is
identical to this.
And you get back to
the conventional thing
that you had in
classical mechanics.
But in quantum mechanics, of
course, they don't commute,
so it's a little bit different.
And moreover this
thing, r, is Hermitian.
L and p are Hermitian but
when you take the Hermitian
conjugate, L goes to
the other side of p.
And since they don't commute,
that's not the same thing.
So actually the Hermitian
conjugate of this term is this.
There's an extra minus
sign in hermiticity
when you have a cross product.
So this is the Hermitian
conjugate of this,
this is the Hermitian
conjugate of this second term,
here's the first and
therefore this is actually
a Hermitian operator.
And you can work with it.
Moreover, in the case
of classical mechanics,
it was conserved.
In the case of quantum
mechanics this statement
of conservation
quantum mechanics
is something that in one of the
exercises that you were asked
to try to do this computation
so these computations
are challenging.
They're not all that trivial
and are good exercises.
So this is one of them.
This is practice.
OK this is the vector r.
What about it?
A few more things about
it that are interesting.
Because of the
hermiticity condition
or in-- a way you can
check this directly
in fact was one of the
exercises for you to do,
was p cross L-- you
did it long time ago,
I think-- is equal to minus
L cross b plus 2ih bar p.
This is an identity.
And this identity helps
you write this kind of term
in a way in which you have
just one order of products
and a little extra
term, rather than
having two complicated terms.
So the r can be
written as 1 over me
squared alone, p cross L
minus ihp minus r over r.
For example.
By writing this term as another
p cross L minus that thing
gives you that expression for r.
You have an
alternative expression
in which you solve
for the other one.
So it's 1 over me squared
minus L cross p plus ih bar p.
Now, r-- we need to
understand r better.
That's really the challenge
of this whole derivation.
So we have one thing
that is conserved.
Angular momentum is conserved.
It commutes with
the Hamiltonian.
We have another thing
that is conserved, this r.
But we have to understand
better what it is.
So one thing that you can
ask is, well, r is conserved,
so r squared is
conserved as well.
So r squared, if I can simplify
it-- if I can do the algebra
and simplify it-- it should
not be that complicated.
So again a practice problem was
given to do that computation.
And I think these forms are
useful for that, to work less.
And the computation
gives a very nice result,
where r squared is equal
to 1 plus 2 H over me
to the fourth L squared
plus h bar squared.
Kind of a strange result
if you think about it.
People that want to
do this classically
first would find that
there's no h squared.
And here, this h, is that
whole h that we have here.
It's a complicated thing.
So this right hand side
is quite substantial.
You don't have to worry
that h is in this side
or whether it's
on the other side
because h commutes
with L. L is conserved.
So h appears like that.
And this, again, is the
result of another computation.
So we've learned something.
r-- oh, I'm sorry,
this is r squared.
Apologies.
r is conserved.
r squared must be conserved
because if h commutes with r
it commutes with
r squared as well.
And therefore whatever you
see on the right hand side,
the whole thing
must be conserved.
And h is conserved, of course.
And L squared is conserved.
Now we need one more property
of a relation-- you see,
you have to do these things.
Even if you probably don't have
an inspiration at this moment
how you're going to
try to understand this,
there are things
that just curiosity
should tell that you should do.
We have L, we do L squared.
It's an important operator.
OK.
We had r, we did r squared,
which is an important operator.
But one thing we
can do is L dot r.
It's a good question
what L dot r is.
So what is L dot r?
So-- or r dot L. What is it?
Well a few things that
are important to note
are that you did
show before that you
know that r dot L,
little r dot L, is 0.
And little p dot L is 0.
These are obvious
classically, because L
is perpendicular
to both r and p.
But quantum mechanically
they take a little more work.
They're not complicated,
but you've shown those two.
So if you have r dot
L, you would have,
for example, here--
r dot L, you would
have to do and think
of this whole r
and put an L on the right.
Well this little r dotted with
the L on the right would be 0.
That p dotted with L on
the right would be 0.
And we're almost there,
but p cross L dot L,
well, what is that?
Let me talk about it here.
P cross L dot L--
so this is part
of the computation of this
r dot L. We've already
seen this term
will give nothing,
this term will give nothing.
But this term could
give something.
So when you face
something like that,
maybe you say,
well, I don't know
any identities I
should be using here.
So you just do it.
Then you say, this
is i-th component
of this vector times
the i-th of that.
So it's epsilon ijkpjLkLi.
And then you say look this
looks a little-- you could
say many things that are wrong
and get the right answer.
So you could say,
oh, ki symmetric
and ki anti-symmetric.
But that's wrong, because
these k and i are not
symmetric really because
these operators don't commute.
So the answer will be zero, but
for a more complicated reason.
So what do you have in here?
ki.
Let's move the i to the end
of the epsilon, so jkipjLkLi.
And now you see this part
is pj L cross cross L j.
Is the cross product of this.
But what is L cross L?
You probably remember.
This is ih bar L
L cross L, that's
the computation in relation
of angular momentum.
In case you kind
of don't remember
it was ih bar L. Like that.
So now p dot L is anyway 0.
So this is 0.
So it's kind of--
it's a little delicate
to do these computations.
But so since that term is
zero, this thing is zero.
Now you may as
well-- r dot L is 0.
Is L dot r also 0?
It's not all that obvious
you can even do that.
Well in a second we'll see
that that's true as well.
L dot r and r dot
L, capital R, are 0.
Let's remember-- let's
continue-- let's see,
I wanted to number some
of these equations.
We're going to need them.
So this will be equation one.
This will be equation two,
it's an important one.
Now what was-- let me
remind you of a notation
we also had about vectors
and their rotations.
Vector under rotations.
So what was a vector,
Vi, under rotations
was something that you had LiVj
equals ih bar epsilon ijkvk.
So there is a way to write
this with cross products that
is useful in some cases.
So I will do it.
You probably have seen
that in the notes,
but let me remind you.
Consider this product,
L cross V plus V
cross L and the i-th
component of it.
i-th component of this product.
So this is epsilon ijk and
you have LjVk plus VjLk.
Now in this term you
can do something nice.
If you think of it
like expanded out,
you have the second
term has epsilon ijkVjk.
Change j for k.
If you change j for
k, this will be VkLj.
And these would have
the opposite order.
But this order can be changed
up to the cost of a minus sign.
So I claim this is ijk-- first
term is the same-- minus VkLj.
So in the second term,
for this term alone, we've
done for this term, multiplied
with this of course,
we've done j and k relabeling.
But this is nothing else than
the commutator of L with V.
So this is epsilon ijkLjVk.
That's epsilon ijk, and
this is epsilon jkp or LVL.
Now, 2 epsilons with
2 common indices
is something that it simple.
It's a commutator dealt
on the other indices.
Now it's better if they are sort
of all aligned in the same way,
but they kind of are because
this L, without paying a price,
can be put as the first index.
So you have jk as
the second and third
and-- jk as the
second and third--
once L has been moved
to the first position.
So this thing is
2 times delta iL.
And there's an h bar,
ih bar I forgot here.
ih bar.
2 delta ik ih bar iL ih bar VL.
So this is 2 ih bar Vi.
So this whole thing the i-th
component of this thing,
using this commutation
relation is this.
So what we've learned
is that L cross
V plus V cross L you
see go to 2 ih bar V.
And that's a statement as a
vector relation of the fact
that V is a vector
in the rotations.
So for V to be a vector in
the rotations means this.
And if you wish, it
means this thing as well.
It's just another
thing of what it means.
Now R is a vector
in the rotations.
This capital R. Why?
You've shown that if you have
a vector in the rotations
and you multiply it by another
vector in the rotations
under the cross
product, it's still
a vector in the rotations.
So this is a vector in
the rotations, this is,
and this is a vector
in the rotations.
R is a vector in the rotations.
So this capital R is a
vector on the rotations,
which means two things.
It means it satisfies
this kind of equation.
So r cross-- or L cross R plus
R cross L is equal to ih bar R.
So R is a vector
in the rotation.
It's a fact beyond doubt.
And that means that we now
know the commutation relations
between L and R. So we're
starting to put together
this picture in which
we get familiar with R
and the commutators
that are possible.
So I can summarize it here.
L dot R LiRj is ih
bar epsilon ijkRk.
That's the same statement as
this one but in components.
And now you see why R dot
L is equal to L dot R.
Because actually if you put the
same two indices here, i and i,
you get zero.
So when you have R dot L you
have R1L1 plus R2L2 plus R3L3.
And each of these
two commute when
the two indices are the same.
Because of the epsilon.
So R dot L is 0.
And now you also appreciate
that L dot R is also 0, too.
OK.
Now comes, in a sense, the most
difficult of all calculations.
Even if this seemed
a little easy.
But you can get
quite far with it.
So what do you do with Ls?
You computed L
commutators and you
got the algebra of
angular momentum.
Over here.
This is the algebra
for angular momentum.
And this kind of
nontrivial calculation,
you did it by building results.
You knew how R was a
vector in the rotation
or how p was a vector
in the rotation.
You multiplied the two of them,
and it was not so difficult.
But the calculation that
you really need to do now
is the calculation of the
commutator say of Ri with Rj.
And that looks like a
little bit of a nightmare.
You have to commute this
whole thing with itself.
Lots of p's, L's, R's.
1 over R's, those
don't commute with p.
You remember that.
So this kind of calculation
done by brute force.
You're talking a day, probably.
I think so.
And probably it
becomes a mess, but.
You'll find a little trick
helps to organize it better.
It's less of a
mess, but still you
don't get it and--
try several times.
So what we're going
to do is try to think
of what the answer could
be by some arguments.
And then once we know
what the answer can be,
there's still one
calculation to be done.
That I will probably
put in the notes,
but it's not a difficult one.
And the answer just pops out.
So the question is what is R
cross R. R cross R is really
what we have when we
have this commutator.
So we need to know what R cross
R is, just like L cross L.
Now R is not likely to
be an angular momentum.
It's a vector but it's
not an angular momentum.
Has nothing to do with it.
It's more complicated.
So what is R cross R
quantum-mechanically?
Classically, of course,
it would be zero.
So first thing is you think
of what this should be.
We have a vector, because the
cross product of two vectors.
Now I want to emphasize
one other thing,
that it should be this
thing-- R cross R-- is
tantamount to this thing.
What is this thing?
It should be
actually proportional
to some conserved quantity.
And the reason is
quite interesting.
So this is a small aside here.
If some operator
is conserved, it
commutes with the Hamiltonian.
Say if S1 and S2 are symmetries,
that means that S1 with h
is equal to S2 with
h is equal to zero.
Then the claim is that the
commutator of this S1 and S2
claim S1 commutator with
S2 is also a symmetry.
So the reason is
because commutator
of S1 S2 commutator with h
is equal actually to zero.
And why would it
be equal to zero?
It's because of the
so-called Jacobi
identity for commutators.
You'll remember when you
have three things like that,
this term is equal to
1-- this term plus 1,
in which you cycle them.
And plus another one
where you cycle them again
is equal to zero.
That's a Jacobi identity.
And in those cyclings
you get an h with S2,
for example, that is zero.
And then an h with
S1, which is zero.
So you use these things
here and you prove that.
So I write here, by Jacobi.
So if you have a
conserved-- this
is the great thing about
conserved quantities,
if you have one conserved
quantity, it's OK.
But if you have two,
you're in business.
Because you can then take the
commutator of these two and you
get another conserved quantity.
And then more commutators and
you keep taking commutators
and if you're lucky you get all
of the conserved quantities.
So here R cross R refers
to this commutator.
So whatever is on the
right should be a vector
and should be conserved.
And what are our
conserved vectors?
Well our conserved
vectors-- candidates here--
are L, R itself, and L cross
R. That's pretty much it.
L and R are our only conserved
things, so it better be that.
Still this is far too much.
So there could be
a term proportional
to L, a term proportional to R,
a term proportional to L dot R.
So this kind of analysis
is based by something
that Julian Schwinger did.
This same guy that
actually did quantum
electrodynamics along
with Feynman and Tomonaga.
And he's the one of
those who invented
the trick of using
three-dimensional angular
momentum for the
two-dimensional oscillator.
And had lots of bags of tricks.
So actually this whole
discussion of the hydrogen
atom-- most books just say,
well, these calculations are
hopeless.
Let me give you the answers.
Schwinger, on the other hand, in
his book on quantum mechanics--
which is kind of interesting
but very idiosyncratic--
finds a trick to do
every calculation.
So you never get
into a big mess.
He's absolutely elegant
and keeps pulling tricks
from the bag.
So this is one of those tricks.
Basically he goes through
the following analysis now
and says, look, suppose
I have the vector R
and I do a parity
transformation.
I change it for minus R.
What happens under
those circumstances?
Well the momentum is
the rate of change of R,
should also change sign.
Quantum mechanically
this is consistent,
because a commutation between
R and p should give you h bar.
And if R changes, p
should change sign.
But now when you do this,
L, which is R cross p,
just goes to L. And R,
however, changes sign
because L doesn't change
sign but p does and R does.
So under these changes--
so this is the originator,
the troublemaker and
then everybody else
follows-- R also changes sign.
So this is extremely powerful
because if you imagine
this being equal to
something, well it
should be consistent
with the symmetries.
So as I change R to minus
R, capital R changes sign
but the left hand side
doesn't change sign.
Therefore the right hand
side should not change sign.
And R changes sign and
L cross R changes sign.
So computation kind of
finished because the only thing
you can get on the right is L.
This is the kind of
thing that you do
and probably if you
were writing a paper on
that you would anyway
do the calculation.
The silly way,
the- the right way.
But this is quite save of times.
So actually what
you have learned
is that R cross R is equal to
some scalar conserved quantity,
which is something that
is conserved that could
be like an h, for example, here.
But it's a scalar.
And, L.
Well once you know that much,
it doesn't take much work
to do this and to
calculate what it is.
But I will skip
that calculation.
This is the sort of
thoughtful part of it.
And R cross R turns out to
be ih bar minus 2 h again.
h shows up in several
places, like here,
so it tends-- it has
a tendency to show up.
me to the fourth L.
So this is our equation
for-- and in a sense,
all the hard work has been done.
Because now you have a complete
understanding of these two
vectors, L and R. You
know what L squared is,
what R squared is,
what L dot R is.
And you know all
the commutators,
you know the commutation of L
with L, L with R, and R with R.
You've done all
the algebraic work.
And the question is, how
do we proceed from now
to solve the hydrogen atom.
So the way we proceed
is kind of interesting.
We're going to try to
build from this L that
is an angular momentum.
And this R that is not
an angular momentum.
Two sets of angular momenta.
You have two vectors.
So somehow we want to try to
combine them in such a way
that we can invent
two angular momenta.
Just like the
angular momentum in
the two-dimensional
harmonic oscillator.
It was not directly
through angular momentum,
but was mathematical
angular momentum.
These two angular momenta we're
going to build, one of them
is going to be recognizable.
The other one is going to
be a little unfamiliar.
But now I have to do
something that-- it
may sound a little
unusual, but is
necessary to simplify our life.
I want to say some
words that will
allow me to think of
this h here as a number.
And would allow me to think
of this h as a number.
So here's what
we're going to say.
It's an assumption--
it's no assumption,
but it sounds like
an assumption.
But there's no
assumption whatsoever.
We say the following:
this hydrogen atom
is going to have some states.
So let's assume there is one
state, and it has some energy.
If I have that state
with some energy, well,
that would be the
end of the story.
But in fact, the
thing that they want
to allow the possibility for is
that at that the energy there
are more states.
One state would be OK,
maybe sometimes it happens.
But in general there are
more states at that energy.
So I don't-- I'm not making any
physical assumption to state
that there is a subspace
of degenerate states.
And in that subspace
of degenerate states,
there may be just one
state, there are two states,
there are three
states, but there's
subspace of degenerate
states that have some energy.
And I'm going to work
in that subspace.
And all the
operators that I have
are going to be acting
in that subspace.
And I'm going to
analyze subspace
by subspace of
different energies.
So we're going to
work with one subspace
of degenerate energies.
And if I have, for example,
the operator R squared
acting on any state
of that subspace,
since h commutes
with L squared, h
can go here, acts on this
thing, becomes a number.
So you might as well
put a number here.
You might as well put
a number here as well.
It has to be stated like that.
Carefully.
We're going to work on
a degenerate subspace
of some energy.
But then we can treat
the h as a number.
So let me say it here.
We'll work in a
degenerate subspace
with eigenvalues of h equal
to h prime, for h prime.
Now I want to write some numbers
here to simplify my algebra.
So without loss of
generality we put
what this dimensionless--
this is dimensionless.
I'm sorry, this is
not dimensionless.
This one has units of energy.
This is roughly
the right energy,
with this one would be the right
energy for the ground state.
Now we don't know
the energies and this
is going to give us
the energies as well.
So without solving the
differential equation,
we're going to get the energies.
So if I say, well that's
the energies you would say,
come on, you're cheating.
So I'll put one over nu squared
where nu can be anything.
Nu is real.
And that's just a
way to write things
in order to simplify
the algebra.
I don't know what nu is.
How you say-- you don't know,
but you have this in mind
and it's going to
be an integer, sure.
That's what good
notation is all about.
You write things and
then, you know, it's nu.
You don't call it N. Because
you don't know it's an integer.
You call it nu, and you proceed.
So once you have
called it nu, you
see here that, well, that's
what we call h really.
h will be-- this h prime
is kind of not necessary.
This is what-- where h
becomes in every formula.
So from here you get that
minus 2h over me to the fourth
is 1 over h squared nu squared.
I have a minus here, I'm sorry.
2h minus me to the fourth
down is h squared nu squared.
So we can substitute
that in our nice formulas
that hme to the fourth so
our formulas four and five
have become-- I'm going
to use this blackboard.
Any blackboard where I
don't have a formula boxed
can be erased.
So I will continue here.
And so what do we have?
R cross R, from that
formula, well this thing
is over there minus 2h
over me to the fourth,
you substitute it in here.
So it's i over h
bar, one over nu
squared L. Doesn't
look that bad.
And, R squared is equal to 1
minus 1 over h bar nu squared.
Like this.
L squared plus h squared.
2h, that's minus h
squared nu squared.
Yeah.
So these are nice formulas.
These are already quite clean.
We'll call them
five, equation five.
I still want to rewrite
them in a way that perhaps
is a little more
understandable or suggestive.
I will put an h bar nu
together with each R.
So h nu R cross h
nu R is equal to ih
bar L. Makes it look nice.
Then for this one
you'll put h squared
nu squared R squared is equal
to h squared nu squared minus 1
minus L squared.
It's sort of trivial algebra.
You multiply by h squared
nu squared, you get this.
You get h squared nu squared
minus L squared because it's
all multiplied minus h squared.
So these two equations,
five, have become six.
So five and six are
really the same equations.
Nothing much has been done.
And if you wish, in
terms of commutators
this equation says that the
commutator h nu Ri with h nu Rj
is equal to ih
bar epsilon ijkLk.
H cross this thing h nu R, h nu
R cross equal iHL in components
means this.
That is not totally obvious.
It requires a small computation,
but is the same computation
that shows that
this thing is really
LiLj equal ih bar epsilon ijkLk.
In which these L's
have now become R's.
OK so, we've cleaned
up everything.
We've made great progress
even though at this moment
it still looks like we haven't
solved the problem at all.
But we're very close.
So are there any questions
about what we've done so far?
Have I lost you in the
algebra, or any goals here?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Why is R cross
R not a commutation?
Why would we expect that
to not be a commutation?
PROFESSOR: In general, it's
the same thing as here.
L cross L is this.
The commutator of two Hermitian
operators is anti-Hermitian.
So there's always
an i over there.
Other questions?
It's good, you have
to-- you should
worry about those things.
Are the units right, or
the right number of i's
on the right hand side.
That's a great way
to catch mistakes.
OK so we're there.
And now it should
really almost look
reasonable to do what
we're going to do.
h nu R with h nu R
gives you like L.
So you have L with L,
form angular momentum.
L and R are vectors in
their angular momentum.
Now R cross R is L.
And with these units,
h nu R and h nu R
looks like it has
the units of angular momentum.
So h nu R can be added
to angular momentum
to form more angular momentum.
So that's exactly what
we're going to do.
So here it comes.
Key step.
J1-- I'm going to define
two angular momenta.
Well, we hope that they
are angular momenta.
L plus h nu R. And J2, one
half L minus h nu R. These
are definitions.
It's just defining
two operators.
We hope something good
happens with these operators,
but at this moment
you don't know.
It's a good suggestion
because of the units
match and all that stuff.
So this is going to be
our definitions, seven.
And from these of course follows
that L, the quantity we know,
is J1 plus J2.
And R, or h nu R,
is J1 minus J2.
You solve in the other way.
Now my first claim is
that J1 and J2 commute.
Commute with each other.
So these are nice,
commuting angular momenta.
Now this computation has
to be done-- let me-- yeah,
we can do it.
J1i with J2J.
It's one half and
one half gives you
one quarter of Li plus h nu
Ri with LJ minus h nu RJ.
Now the question
is where do I-- I
think I can erase most
of this blackboard.
I can leave this formula.
It's kind of the only
very much needed one.
So I'll continue with
this computation here.
This gives me one quarter-- and
we have a big parentheses-- ih
bar epsilon iJkLk.
For the commutator of these two.
And then you have the
commutator of the cross terms.
So what do they look like?
They look like minus h nu
Li with RJ, and minus h
nu Ri with-- no.
So I have minus h nu
Li with RJ, and now I
have a plus of this term.
But I will write this as a
minus h nu of LJ with Ri.
Those are the two
cross products.
And then finally we have this
thing, the h nu with h nu Rijk.
So I have minus h nu squared,
and you have then RiRJk.
No, I'll do it this way.
I'm sorry.
You have minus over there,
and I have this thing
so it's minus ih bar epsilon
iJkLk from the last two
commutators.
So this one you use
essentially equation six.
Now look.
This thing and
this thing cancels.
And these two terms, they
actually cancel as well.
Because here you
get an epsilon iJR.
And here there's an
epsilon Ji something.
So these two terms
actually add up to zero.
And this is zero.
So indeed, J1i and
J2i-- 2J-- is zero.
And these are commuting things.
I wanted to say commuting
angular momentum,
but not quite yet.
Haven't shown their
angular momenta.
So how do we show
their angular momenta?
We have to try it and
see if they really
do form an algebra
of angular momentum.
So again, for saving room, I'm
going to erase this formula.
It will reappear
in lecture notes.
But now it should go.
So the next computation is
something that I want to do.
J1 cross J1 or the
J2 cross J2, to see
if they form angular momenta.
And I want to do
them simultaneously,
so I will do one
quarter of J1 cross
J2 would be L plus minus h nu
R cross L plus minus h nu R.
OK that doesn't look bad at
all, especially because we
have all these
formulas for products.
So look, you have L
cross L, which we know.
Then you have L cross
R plus R cross L
that is conveniently here.
And finally, you have R
cross R which is here.
So it's all sort
of done in a way
that the composition
should be easy.
So indeed 1 over 4
L cross L gives you
an ih bar L. From L
cross L. From these ones,
you get plus minus
with plus minus.
It's always plus but
you get another ihL.
So you get another ihL.
And then you get plus minus
L cross h nu R plus h nu R
cross L. So here you get
one quarter of 2 ihL.
And look at this formula, just
put an h nu here and h nu here
and an h nu here.
So you get plus minus 2 ih
from here and an h nu R.
OK so the twos and the fours
and the iH's go out and then you
get ih times one half
times L plus minus h nu R,
which is either J1 or J2.
So, very nicely,
we've shown that J1
cross J1 is ih bar J1 and
J2 cross J2 is ih bar J2.
And now finally you
can say that you've
discovered two independent
angular momenta in the hydrogen
atom.
You did have an angular
momentum on an R vector,
and all of our work has
gone into showing now
that you have two
angular momenta.
Pretty much we're
at the end of this
because, after we do one more
little thing, we're there.
So let me do it here.
I will not need these
equations anymore.
Except this one I will need.
So
L dot R is zero.
So from L dot R
equals zero, this time
you get J1 plus J2 is
equal to-- no, times--
J1 minus J2 is equal to zero.
Now J1 and J2 commute.
So the cross terms vanish.
J1 and J2 commute.
So this implies that J1
squared is equal to J2 squared.
Now this is a very
surprising thing.
These two angular momenta
have the same length squared.
Let's look a little more at
the length squared of it.
So let's, for
example, square J1.
Well, if I square J1, I have one
fourth L squared plus h squared
nu squared R squared.
No L dot R term,
because L dot R is 0.
And h squared nu squared
R squared is here.
So this is good news.
This is one fourth L
squared plus h squared
nu squared minus
1 minus L squared.
The L squared cancels.
And you've got that J1
equals to J2 squared.
And it's equal to one fourth of
h squared nu squared minus 1.
OK.
Well the problem
has been solved,
even if you don't
notice at this moment.
It's all solved.
Why?
You've been talking
a degenerate subspace
with angular momentum
with equal energies.
And there's two
angular momenta there.
And their squares equal
to the same thing.
So these two angular
momenta, our squares
are the same and the
square is precisely what
we call h squared J times J
plus 1, where j J is quantized.
It can be zero, one
half, one, all of this.
So here comes a quantization.
J squared being nu squared, we
didn't know what nu squared is,
but it's now equal
to these things.
So at this moment, things
have been quantized.
And let's look into a little
more detail what has happened
and confirm that we got
everything we wanted.
So let me write that
equation again here.
J1 squared is equal J2 squared
is equal to one quarter
h squared nu squared
minus 1, which
is h squared J times J plus 1.
So cancel the h squares
and solve for nu squared.
Nu squared would
be 1 plus 4J times
J plus 1, which is 4J
squared plus 4J plus 1,
which is 2J plus 1 squared.
That's pretty neat.
Why is it so neat?
Because as J is equal to
zero, all the possible values
of angular momentum--
three halves,
all these things-- nu,
which is 2J plus 1,
will be equal to 1, 2,
3, 4-- all the integers.
And what was nu?
It was the values
of the energies.
So actually you've
proven the spectrum.
Nu has come out to
be either 1, 2, 3,
but you have all representations
of angular momentum.
You have the
singlet, the spin one
half-- where are the spins here?
Nowhere.
There was an electron,
a proton, we never
put spin for the hydrogen atom.
But it all shows up as
these representations
in which they come along.
Even more is true, as
we will see right away
and confirm that everything
really shows up the right way.
So what happened now?
We have two independent,
equal angular momentum.
So what is this degenerate
subspace we were inventing?
Is the space J, which is
J1 and m1 tensor product
with J, which is J2
but has the same value
because the squares
are the same, m2.
So this is an uncoupled basis.
Uncoupled basis of states
in the degenerate subspace.
And now, you know, it's
all a little surreal
because these don't look
like our states at all.
But this is the way
algebraically they show up.
We choose our value of J, we
have then that nu is equal
to this and for that value of
J there's some values of m's.
And therefore, this must
be the degenerate subspace.
So this is nothing
but the tensor product
of a J multiplet
with a J multiplet.
Where J is that integer here.
And what is the tensor
product of a J multiplet?
First, J is for J1.
The second J is for J2.
So at this moment
of course we're
calling this N for
the quantum number.
But what is this thing?
This is 2J plus 2J minus
1 plus-- all the way
up to the singlet.
But what are these
representations of?
Well here we have
J1 and here is J2.
These must be the
ones of the sum.
But who is the sum, L?
So these are the L
representations that you get.
L is your angular momentum.
L representations.
And if 2J plus 1 is N,
you got a representation
with L equals N minus
1, because 2J plus 1
is N, L equals N minus 2,
all the way up to L equals 0.
Therefore, you get precisely
this whole structure.
So, just in time as
we get to 2 o'clock,
we've finished the quantization
of the hydrogen atom.
We've finished 805.
I hope you enjoyed.
I did a lot. [INAUDIBLE]
and Will did, too.
Good luck and
we'll see you soon.